مواقع التواصل تسمح للاطفال بالانضمام
لخدماتها عند بلوغهم سن ال 13 من اعمارهم
لكن اصوات عده تطالب برفع الحد الادنى لسن
الاستخدام بالفعل هو جدال دائر مشاهدينا
في الولايات المتحده ما بين اطباء ومختصين
ومشرعين وحتى في الكونجرس الذي يبحث الان
قانونا لهذا الهدف يستشهد المؤيدون لرفع
السن بابحاث مختلفه توضح اضرار هذه
المنصات على المراهقين اهمها التاثير
السلبي على الصحه العقليه المؤيدون
يعتقدون ان صغار المراهقين ليسوا بالنضج
الكافي للتحكم بانفعالات هم وتجنب ضغوطات
المقارنه مع اقرانهم وسوشيال ميديا تدفعهم
دائما لتفاعل مع اشياء من المحتمل ان
يتجاهلها الكبار على العموم الكثيرون
اتفقوا على ان السن السادس عشر ربما يكون
الحد الادنى المناسب للانضمام الى تطبيقات
التواصل الاجتماعي
عربيه بدورنا سالنا
مراه العراق والسعوديه عن رايهم بموضوع
منع وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عن المراهقين
في عمر 13 عاما ولكن كيف يحمون انفسهم في
هذا الفضاء الواسع هذا ما سالناهم دعونا
نتابع
[موسيقى]
اول حساب انشاته وانا عندي عشر سنين
انشات اول حساب لي سنه 2014 كان وقت عمري
12 سنه حساب الاول مره في 2018 الاسباب
عائليه شيء اتواصل مع عائلتي وكان عمري 11
سنه فقط سويت حسابي في السوشل ميديا لما
كنت الصف الرابع وكان عمري عشر سنين
[موسيقى]
طبعا من حق المراه
بطريقه عقلانيه بس انه يمنعون الشخص من
استخدام الشخص من حقوقهم ما احس مقنع عشان
كنت صحباتي حيكون عندهم حسابات في
السوشيال ميديا وانا ما حيكون عندي فهكون
مختلفه عنهم وما حقدر اتواصل معهم كثير
طبعا انا ضد هذه الحمله النمنع السوشيال
ميديا عن عن
الفعل في عمري لان احنا نواكب التطور
والتكنولوجيا في 2023
واغلب وبقينا بنتواصل عن طريق السوشيال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تجربه ايجابيه في السوشل ميديا عشان حد
يتواصل مع عائلتي وصحباتي اكثر وكمان اقدر
اتعلم اشياء جديده في الحياه من السوشيال
ميديا
تعرفت على ناس جدد واحيانا تفيدنا
بالدراسه يعني نقدر نتواصل
مع المدرسين الخاصين بالماده مالنا اما
تجربتي مع السوشيال ميديا اكيد طبعا
ايجابيه لاني انا بدور على المحتوى
الترفيهي
وببتعد عن المحتويات السلبيه في السوشيال
ميديا
تجربه ايجابيه لان بدرس من عليها وبقدر
اتواصل مع زمايلي وتجربه ايجابيه
[موسيقى]
بحمي نفس الملف ابتعد عن المحتوى السلبي
وبشاهد الايجابيه وما بحكي مع حدا في
السوشيال ميديا او في مواقع التواصل الا
لما اكون عارفه في الحياه الواقعيه واي
حدا بعرف عن السوشيال ميديا بحاول ابتعد
عنه ما احكي ما اتواصل معه
بالحياه باشياء ايجابيه اشياء سلبيه لكن
انا استخدمتها الضوابط واشراف الي وهي شنو
نتفادى المشاكل واضرار الشرار لو احد غريب
ضافني ما اقبله ولو احد ضايقني حسويلي
بلوك واروح اقول لاهلي ما بقدرش احمي نفسي
من السوشيال ميديا لانها يعتبر اغلى مني
معظم
كلهم تقريبا بقولوا تجربتهم كانت ايجابيه
من على السوشيال ميديا وهن قادرين على
حمايه انفسهم
نناقش هذا الموضوع طبعا مشاهدينا معنا
الان في الاستوديو المتخصصه في القياس
والتقويم التربوي والنفسيه دكتوره اسماء
ادلبي اهلا بك دكتوره اسماء معنا في صباح
العربيه
طيب اكيد سمعتي شو مراهقين مختلفين من عده
دول عربيه شو اجابوا على هذا الموضوع
وبعتقد لو سالنا اي طفل
حتى تحت سنه 13 رح يدافع عن ما يعتقد بانه
حقه انه يكون على السوشيال ميديا اكيد
بشكل بشكل هائل خلينا نحكي تربويا وسلوكيا
ماذا يعني انه يكون طفل باقل عمره اقل من
13 عاما او 16 عاما عنده على مواقع
التواصل تمام حقيقه هي خلينا نقول كارثه
تربويه ممكن توصل لكارثه تربويه تؤثر على
نفسيه الطفل تؤثر على نمو العقلي على نمو
الجسدي وعلى نمو العاطفي عندها مجموعه من
التاثيرات اللي هي حقيقه حساسه عند الفئه
اللي ممكن نقول يافعين او مراهقين بهذه
الفتره هويتهم الرقميه مو موجوده هويتهم
الشخصيه عم تنمو عم يبحثوا عن من انا وفق
هذا البحث بيبلش يشوفه طبعا بهذا الفتره
كتير بتاثر بالاقران فبيبلشوا يشوفوا
مجموعه من الترندات الترندات نماذج مثل ما
بنشوف الترند هي شي سريع بيطلع اليوم بكره
بيختفي بيطلع اليوم بكره بيختفي اللي ممكن
يكون اليوم شي موضه وفني بكره حيصير ممل
وسخيف فبالتالي هون الهويه بتتعرض لتشوي
عم نلاحظ انه في عنا خلل حقيقه بالنسيج
المجتمعي ممكن يصير مجموعه من الضغط
الانفعالي عند الطفل اللي بتبلش يشوف
الحياه بتوقعات مرتفعه بدا يشوف مثلا
بحد ذاته عم يعمل ضغط مجتمعي على الشباب
بشوفوا مجموعه من النماذج اللي هي عند
الايجابيه المفرطه اللي عندها نوع من
انواع التظاهر او المال الماديه المبالغ
فيها بنلاقي بعض الاشخاص اللي هن
المشهورين على مواقع التواصل الافتراضي
بيلبسوا افضل لبس
احسن ماركات
افخم سيارات فبيطلع للنجاح بشوفه بطريقه
كتير مبالغ فيها بيضغط هذا الشيء على
شعوره نفسي وبالتالي ممكن يسبب انتحار
ممكن يسبب قلق توتر عدم قبول للواقع خليني
اسالك دكتور اسماء اليوم الاهل يعني على
جيلي او حتى اللي قبلي او اللي بعده ربما
احنا نقول بالكويت القرقاشه الخشخاشه شو
بتسموها
لا لا يلعبون فيها الطفل تلهيه فبالتالي
اليوم
الجهاز الموبايل او التليفون هو اصبح يعطى
للطفل لكي يسكت
طيب في عمر صغير الاهل يعطون الطفل نجي
نمنعه ونقول له والله لا تستخدم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الا في سن 16 سنه او
اكثر من 13 سنه بينما احنا ايضا نطالب
والمدرسه والتعليم يكون عبره
يعني الاجهزه اللوحيه هذا التناقض
المجتمعي الطفل هذا ما ذنبه فيه
سؤالك جدا جميل استاذ عادل خلينا نقول سنه
نحن ما المفروض نعطي اطفالنا
بمواقع التواصل الافتراضي بطريقه مفتوحه
كتير لانه نحن ما بنعطي طفلنا يقود سياره
بناء على فقط العمر ولكن بناء على دراسه
هل هو عنده قدره على تحليل المشكلات هل
عنده قدره على تحليل المخاطر هل عنده قدره
على التواصل فعالها لانه قدره على التعامل
مع التنمر الاجتماعي هل عنده قدره على عدم
الضغط المقارنه
بهذه الامور دكتور اسماء
في السابق كانوا يقولون الحياه خير مدرسه
اليوم في مواقع التواصل وفي العالم
الافتراضي اصبح لهم لغتهم اصبح لهم
طريقتهم في الحوار صحيح صحيح ولكن هو
تواصل
عم يمنعهم اوقات
من المباشر
مقدرا الشاب ممكن ما يقدر يعمل او تواصل
فعال مع المحيط بالفعل منعزل فعليا يعني
مضبوط الى حد ما انا عم بحس انه اطفالي
بفضلوا انهم يلعبوا مع اقرانهم واصدقائهم
اون لاين اكثر من انه يشوفوا بعض بس قبل
ما ننهي انا حبيت بس يعني القي الضوء على
نقطه تانيه مهمه طب ما انا اذا منعت
اطفالي وللاسف حتى اقل من سن 13 سنه قد ما
نقوا اضطريت انه افتح لهم حسابات سوشيال
ميديا فانا اذا منعتهم من ذلك ممكن يكون
في ضرر نفسي عليهم لانه راح يحسوا انه هم
مختلفين عن اقرانهم
خارج نطاق او مش مواكبين الحياه العصريه
صحيح ما عنده حتى لغه تواصل مع اقران وفي
حال هو كان ممنوع كليا مشان هيك هو المنع
هو مو اما او نحن عم نحكي عن نوع من انواع
التقنين لانه نحن عم نحكي عن مشاكل ممكن
تصير للادمان ممكن يتحولش المراهق لعنده
اعراض انسحابيه مثل اعراض التدخين او
ادمان او المخدرات في حال سحبنا منه
الاجهزه الالكترونيه نحن عم نحكي عن تقنين
لا يكون بطريقه مناسبه يعني والله انا
شايفه الحل صعب بس على كل حال شكرا اسماء
ادلبي المتخصصه في القياس وتقويم التربوي
والنفسي شكرا جزيلا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج
والقزم والاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات